okay so big spoilers ahead for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
several new trailers and tv spots have
been released for the film and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down all the easter eggs hidden
details and things you missed in the
teasers is it unlike athon well we'll
get into it and the first thing i want
to discuss is the monster in the tv spot
that was released on saturday this giant
hulking beast is a big star now in the
teaser and it looks exactly like the
monster that was shown on the poster
there's been a ton of theories saying
that this is c'thon however i think this
tv spot clears up that it isn't during
the teaser it growls to wong and we then
see it in another shot in which it
stands behind him this then pans over to
wonder who appears to be fighting
alongside him however if you zoom in on
the bottom right corner of the screen
you'll notice that there's also an
identical creature in the background
behind here now in case you don't know
cathon was the creator of the darkhold
and he wrote the book below wondergold
mountain which may have been where
wonder was at during the post-credits
scene of one division the book laid
dormant for centuries until it was found
and its dark and dangerous magic was
unleashed in the comics catholic
actually inhabited the body of wonders
for the quicksilver at one point and
because of this many thought that evan
peter's return in one division could
signal his arrival mephisto was like the
the layman's theory but the true classy
gent he was giving yukathon all night
long until the break of dawn now these
monsters are in front of what i believe
are the gates to castle darkhold this is
also called darkhold in the comics but
let's just call it castle dark hole to
avoid any confusion now scarlet witch is
standing in front of a big doorway and
the carvings on the back of it look
exactly like a page from the dark hold
and huge shout outs to everything always
for spotting that detail really lovely
lad so go check out his channel if you
like marvel content now with that being
too i believe these creatures will very
much be the guard dogs to the area and
they'll be attempting to stop the person
entering that's in front of wonder and
wong now i actually think that wong
isn't really in this scene and if you
look at him and play the clip over and
over and over again going lad talking to
my editor steven there keep playing the
clip something seems a bit off the
lighting is slightly wrong and he
doesn't actually seem like he's part of
the scene like wonder is there's not the
red glow surrounding him that's in the
other shot with a monster and therefore
i think that old kevin feige he's just
done his classic trailer trick and put
stuff in to fool us this is because
everyone pretty much knows wonder is the
villain now unless he's dropped wong in
so all our fan theories are wrong about
what's happening in the movie hey that
deserves a thumb up come on come on that
that one was good now they are clearly
trying to make us think that wonder
isn't the big bad by dropping in these
creatures that look like cathon and also
through having wong beside her however
if you look at the monster in the first
shot you can see its eyes are glowing
red and that it's basked in the colour
of chaos magic this colour is also
present on the red ribbon-like monster
that appears to be attacking america and
also defender strange in the second
trailer so yeah i think the theories
about these creatures being summoned by
wonder are indeed correct and that she's
still the bad guy early reports for the
movie that came up before the first
teaser even dropped say that she'll be
sending monsters after america so that
she can steal her powers and these seem
to line up now in case you don't know
america in the comics has the ability to
open up portals but unlike the rest of
the sorcerers these can be into other
dimensions across the multiverse
therefore it makes sense that wander is
trying to take a gift so that she can
find a reality in which her kids are
still alive and this is likely why we
see the two wonders in the second
trailer this is the same house that she
lived in in west view during one
division so i think these leagues do
make a lot of sense sure we have clips
of wong standing alongside her but we
also have clips where she's going to the
illuminati base fighting characters and
getting covered in blood or oil not the
first time she's had a robot made by
ultron splash out on her but we'll not
go there yet we'll keep it pg-13 now
she's going to the cell that we know
america is trapped in so yeah all the
info about her being the villain i think
is true other shots in this teaser also
have her floating above camouflage and
blasting at the wizards we have the
opposite shot of this in the second
trailer with strange in the air and i
believe that they're fighting each other
now the attack on comitage seems like
it's going to be a big action set piece
at the midpoint of the movie we've seen
the grey cloud of smoke roll in and from
what i've been told by leakers this will
actually be read in the movie there's
also shots of wonder levitating in a
circle with candles around her this
lines up with the opening of the first
trailer and if you look at the floor
she's sitting in a circle with a square
like shape in the middle go to the
courtyard of comitage and you might also
notice that there's a circle in the
middle there that looks a lot like the
one that she's levitating in therefore i
think she kicks the crap out of the
wizards and then astral projects herself
in order to follow strange in america
throughout the multiverse other comitage
easter eggs are the wizard with one hand
which can be seen standing next to
america and he appeared in the first
doctor strange movie when stephen went
to meet the sorcerer's supreme for the
first time there is also the shot of
them walking through the garden and we
know from other parts of the trailers
that this also happens when wanda is
doing her speech about being the enemy
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it and i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair i've talked about
this a lot but in case you don't watch
all our videos which yeah i'll never
forgive you these are clearly the same
scenes strange is wearing the same
clothes and even the position of wonder
is exactly the same the entire garden
looks like it's all an illusion and
maybe strange will get her back on the
lunch box but it'll be the one that the
bully has
i could use an avenger
there are other avengers i'll get you
back on the lunch box they do a really
cool bit where she comes across her kids
as part of an illusion and this might
even be carried out by the illuminati
she reaches out to touch them but they
disappear and either this is all
make-believe or it's cooked up by some
of the other characters however it does
seem to be at the part where she's at
the sanctuarium and potentially all the
illusion stuff i've just been telling
you is a load of crap and that's why you
love the channel yet we waste your time
now my other theory where i'm just
throwing everything at the wall until it
sticks is that she's astral projecting
herself into another reality in order to
meet them however i don't think that
she's strong enough to maintain it and
this might be why she has to go after
america now professor x was a big part
of the second trailer and patrick
stewart kept denying it was him i have
to quickly ask everyone's wondering
twitter's buzzing is that your voice in
the doctor strange trailer can you
comment on that at all
who's doctor strange
[Music]
perfect
i for one believe the lad just blink if
kevin feige has a gun pointing at you go
on blink blink if he has now the
illuminati shot is missing a chair in
the middle and according to the leaks x
gon give it to you whilst he's in a
yellow hover chair just like the 90s
cartoon we know that disney are
currently making an x-men 97 tv show for
disney plus and i'd love to see this
work as an origin story for this version
of professor x now i actually think that
this might be the ex who traps wondering
the illusion with her kids and he could
be using it to try and calm her down
however she's stuck in this nightmare of
thinking that they're not with her and
she breaks out of it it could also be
the other wander who can of course warp
reality but i do think it's probably
being carried out by the illuminati now
another detail throughout the trailer is
that wander drops her american accent
and goes back to the sokovian one this
is such a cool little character turned
by elizabeth olsen and she of course did
it at several points in one division to
show she was sort of turning back to the
dark side really nice bit of detail and
yeah absolutely loved it in this trailer
beyond this it's likely that captain
carter will probably be a member too the
poster had her shield on it and
shattered glass and one of the members
does look like her though she is heavily
cloaked in shadow i kind of feel like
the illuminati will be protectors of the
multiverse and this might even be the
one that we met in what if episode 9 had
her facing off against infinite ultron
and helping to beat him might have
earned her a spot on the council really
hoping that she's in it and i'd love to
see more nods to what if because there
were some really great episodes in it
now the book of ashanti is rumored to
also be making a big appearance in the
film in case you haven't read the comics
this is basically the exact opposite of
the darkhold and whereas that's filled
with corrupting darkness it sucks the
life out of you like having to watch
mobius 10 times to do an easter egg
video this is filled with light all fan
theories but this is potentially shown
on the poster and in the scene in which
strange is casting chaos magic you can
catch what looks like it on the floor
potentially stevie boy is going to be
using this to combat the darkhold and he
might also be taking chaos energy from
it to match wander's powers it is
possibly what we see on the pedestal at
the middle of the floating universe and
this might actually be the center of the
multiverse itself now christine palmer
is probably going to be playing a big
role in the film but not the way you
think we know that the mcu version is
going to be getting married as we've
seen her walking down the aisle with
strange standing in the florence pews
now this might be what he wakes up to to
get ready for at the start of the movie
and it's likely that she met someone in
the five years between the snap in the
blip stephen got snapped away in
infinity war and we know that this film
is set roughly between six months and a
year after the events of avengers end
game more like avengers end your
relationship eh
now i doubt christine met someone in
that time and arranged a wedding so i
think what probably happened is that
strange got snapped she didn't and
someone snapped her up can't really
cancel your wedding over someone who
uses a goatee template and so she didn't
do anything in my opinion however
there's also a second christine who'll
be appearing in the illuminati timeline
and this variant looks like it's going
to be important during the second
trailer when they open the hatch door
you can see christine strange and also
america however in some of the recent
teasers she's been removed so either the
first one was a misdirect or this one is
feige loves to play with our emotions so
who knows at this point and there was a
trailer dropped on marvel india recently
titled truth which shows the start of
this scene with the three standing there
so i do think that she is indeed part of
this moment now we know that there will
be several versions of doctor strange
that pop up in the movie the truth
trailer had some extended scenes of
defender strange in it in which we could
see his body floating around he looks
really limp and has likely died after
being killed by the monster that strings
of america if you look closely there are
scores on his face and these later
appear on the zombie looking strange
that shows up on top of the mountain
therefore i kind of think this version
is killed earlier in the movie and then
strange travels to the illuminati
timeline and he sees the statue for him
he's then likely taken in because
they're like what the heck bro is
supposed to be dead and this is when he
goes before the council i kind of hope
that the christine varian was dating him
in this timeline and this would explain
why she goes off with the mcu one now it
is possible that we see his body later
on in the finale and in the shot where
america jumps towards the camera with
the castle behind her if you look in the
bottom right corner you can also catch
what appears to be his body maybe
they're resurrecting with a darkhold
we'll find a way to bring him back but
the trailers make it seem like he's
gonna be a big part of the final few
scenes and there's also sinister strange
who we now know isn't the same version
that was shown in what if however he's
likely had a similar path and if we look
at the top of his sanctorum it's
starting to melt away much like what
happened to the city in that episode
there's also other shots of a city that
has the same effect in the trailer and
the entire place looks completely
abandoned i'm guessing that this is the
universe he's in and at the center of
this destroyed new york is a sanctorum
there are even some special cameos here
as strange walks up to the darkest
sanctuarium and if you look at the
skulls on the floor you can catch black
widow
[Music]
anyway we get a big fight between the
two and sinister strange appears with an
eye in the middle of his forehead this
is something that typically shows
psychic abilities and it was what the
ancient one touched on in the first
doctor strange film before sending
steven plummeting through reality this
has actually appeared a lot of times in
the comics and typically when it tends
to show up it's because strange has gone
a bit evil and he needs calming down
just chill out yeah we'll handle the
breakdown and you just put your fear up
and we'll tell you what happened now as
we mentioned the illuminati is going to
be a big part in the film and for the
last two months there's been lots of
videos discussing the strange glowing
figure in the teaser lots of people have
said it's tom cruise his superior iron
man which hmm there's been that bloody
ryanairy saying it's jonathan mages as
iron lad and then there's your boy kevin
spoilers saying it's maria rambo as a
captain marvel variant the new tv spot
gives us our clearest look at the
character and i'm just gonna say what i
said then look at the hips look at the
boobs to me that's a woman and they also
have the glow around them that captain
marvel has but look at their hands as
well go on take you take your dirty eyes
off their body you pivot look at them
hands you can clearly see a blue glow
emanating from them and as we know
captain marvel's powers pull from the
tesseract and she also does something
similar when firing her blasts therefore
i think this version probably pulls from
a universe where she took the test
flight instead of carol danvers and
that's how she got her powers honestly
i'm just tired of arguing at this point
and i want it over please someone just
leak the movie so we can end this all
now we also have new shots of mordor
fighting strange who he clearly blames
for destroying the multiverse in the
shot of the illuminati we could catch
him walking along the top with his sword
sticking out which he doesn't sheath in
this trailer now other new shots include
the fight in new york with strange
standing on top of a taxi his red cape
is gone so it's likely helping out in
the battle we know from the trailers
that strange will fight the sea creature
gargantos here which was probably
summoned by wonder america appears to be
running in the street and it's likely
going after her which is why strange is
stood in front of her when he cuts the
bus in half
overall there's his entire dream and
nightmare theme laced throughout the
entire teaser and this is backed up by
the song all i have to do is dream by
the everly brothers lovely little tune
there fits in really well especially
with wonder menacingly talking over the
top of it i don't think i'll ever listen
to that song again without thinking of
her showing up to my house and taking my
two twins i think it's really creative
how they've managed to set up strange
and wonderous opposites and they're not
exactly the first people that come to
mind when you when you think about
people facing off against each other
this is very much the magic universe's
civil war and this is of course
reflected in the lines where strange
says every night i dream the same dream
rise wander says every morning the same
nightmare works really well to show how
they're opposite sides of the same coin
and it of course sets up the big battle
that's going to be happening between
them in the film anyway that should
cover everything you've been wondering
about me and as for our thoughts on the
tv spots i honestly think this looks
like it's going to be absolutely bloody
mental now we also have the full runtime
released and the movie will be two hours
and six minutes long this has had a lot
of people complaining because it does
feel quite short however sam raimi has
never really delivered long movies and
most of his films are around the 2 hour
mark even spider-man 2 is just 2 hours
and 7 minutes so the guy definitely has
the ability to deliver fully fleshed out
films without them being overly long
just for the sake of it it's actually
quite nice that we're not going to have
a majorly long movie and because of this
i think the plot will be a lot simpler
than most people expect it to be i'm
guessing that america arrives in the mcu
goes to strange for help who then goes
to wander and this is when she turns
there'll then be a big cat and mouse
chase across the multiverse as they try
to find a way to stop the darkhold's
power over her and that's pretty much
what i imagine is gonna happen does it
need to be three hours but i can also
totally see why people are a bit
cautious over this as we're used to
having really long comic book movies at
this point anyway i'm really excited and
with the movie less than a month away
i'm all aboard the hype train i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know you're punk now we are in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of spider-man now a home on
the 15th of april and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners are the
last one on screen right now so that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want some emails to
watch then check out our moonlight
theories which will be linked on screen
right now we've gone over some of the
best ones from the first episode and
judging by the second one they do seem
might be true might not but uh yeah go
check that out right after this without
the way thanks for sitting through the
video i know you haven't gone because
you're still here uh so yeah bit awkward
but uh i'll see you next time yeah
thanks for letting me down take care
peace